Made it home to Texas very late last night.
We packed our bags, got four hours of sleep,
and headed back to the airport.
Car pick up was very early in the morning.
Loaded up our car, got the kids in,
and it was time to head to Europe.
We're spending the rest of September
and beginning of October in Europe.
Our first stop is Frankfort,
Germany, to drop the kids off.
But once we got to the airport,
we got checked in, checked in our bags,
and then made it through security.
The last three flights we were on,
we've always been late, so we made sure that that was in the case today.
We all had some breakfast,
I grabbed some waters, and it was time to board our first flight.
We were flying to Washington
and then laying over and getting on a flight to Frankfort, Germany.
This flight wasn't that long,
and we managed to keep the kids entertained
before we laid over in Washington and boarded our second flight,
which was an eight hour long flight.
Lucky sat in the front of the plane with rumble,
while I sat with slim and whimsy.
The first thing I need to do when I get on long flights
is do my skincare routine.
My skin gets so dry when I'm on the airplane,
so this is always the first thing I do.
Once I was done with that,
I grabbed whimsy and got her to sleep.
And A couple hours into our flight,
all the babies were asleep,
and I managed to get a couple of hours myself.
Once we landed in Germany and grabbed our suitcases,
one of my first stops had to be the grocery store,
so that's where we went.
Had to stock up on some nostalgic things for me,
especially the tea. I was starving.
So we got some lahmachun and dona,
which always hits the spot.
And just a few hours after this,
we were on a plane to London with whimsy.